[Applause]
it was close to a perfect night for the
crowd at the lexington bar in islington
here in the north london constituency of
labor leader jeremy corbyn many had just
a glimmer of hope when the exit polls
started to trickle in
the mood soon changed
positive magnificent
wonderful i'm feeling very pleased
anything is better than a tory majority
at this rate
uh mahong parliament isn't ideal but
then
i'm just happy that labour are making
some gains it's disappointing to me that
you can imagine what would happen dear
flavor who actually
supported jeremy corman a lot earlier
that we might have been seeing quite a
substantial labor lead
meanwhile the business of counting
balance got underway
each vote checked by hand like here in
lambeth a south london district
and campaigners on the sidelines were
already taking stock
and it looks as though
theresa may has made a bit of a
bit of a blunder really in calling this
election um i'm not entirely sure how
she's getting on with the rest of her
party it's not been a brilliant night
for us
um i think our campaign was uh could
have been better i think everyone
acknowledges that really and i think
everyone will acknowledge that within
the party
i think we could have talked more about
the things that we've done very well
over the last seven years
[Applause]
back at the lexington bar in islington
cheering and celebrations continued into
the early hours for these labor
supporters at least it's a vote to
remember
[Music]
[Applause]